[Music]
and Ferris Bueller's Day Off news
Bueller Bueller anybody what knows that
now I know as a joke I go on the plane
and Ben Stein was it those name right I
think he was at the front greeting
everyone is he doing that jacked off
while the girl was in the pool he's a
different Bueller teacher whose knee I
don't know okay Noel everything Oh is he
but you're reading your monotone guy all
right I'm thinking about rich maja a red
eyes Visine for red eyes submitted by
mr. Popo a woman catches her mechanic
taking a joyride in the car she brought
in for service what just like the movie
yeah doesn't that happen a lot out of
that that happens a lot a lot of people
defending I'm like oh it's just a
[ __ ] ride to Taco Bell it's like a
mile a few blocks away like do it if you
don't [ __ ] pay for my car don't
[ __ ] drive my car like I gave you I
brought the kind of boot crap
Jesus Christ how do you know boo I don't
know man right there on the nipple yeah
is it a muscle oh it's a nipple nipples
not a muscle nice it'll be a lot of fans
right now that's willing the massage it
or suck it fine I'll fix it for you hold
still no but I was reading the comments
on the Facebook thing and they were
saying like it's fine it's like no it's
not fine if he takes my crap for a block
crashes it I'd be [ __ ] pissed
liability yeah you know don't [ __ ] me
because she's my car dude if that bull
[ __ ] crashed my Honda Element I'd be
so mad you would snap [ __ ] the Tesla
dude the Holliman dude if you [ __ ]
touch it crash my Honda what would you
do dude what would you do you know what
I would give him stern words I would
look at him you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] about yeah I [ __ ] him up I
told you I hippie box [ __ ] the air
around them yeah that's it I don't care
my car's a lease that's what's in my
search warrant you actually bought that
yeah I think he really cared about that
one cuz he couldn't stop talking about
it for the last two years and Jill was
like you cannot get that car yeah what
is really
I love that cop cruisers in my that way
it's just like them it's like the Swiss
Army knife car there's like constant
utility with it you know ice because
because it's my joys of sports they
weren't supposed to bring one out last
year a brand new one and they did it
pitched stops trying to get that [ __ ]
jiggle FG cruises have been discontinued
so you can sell it even if you had it
for a while for more than what you gotta
for yeah that's amazing that's the same
with a Supra yeah oh yeah I don't know I
love the car I want to go back and look
for all the cars that I had and I want
to buy them and make them back to normal
but two of my cars burned down you know
what I don't know doesn't hurt me though
like so let's say he did go on a joy I
remember I didn't know who the [ __ ]
cares as long as the cars fixed what
about the mileage the mileage dude like
Ferris Bueller
how much miles did he put on it though
Ferris Bueller I don't know but they had
they try going to reverse though the car
came back fixed and he only put like 30
50 miles on it okay what if he there's a
ding on it oh that's different they got
to fix that [ __ ] but you don't find out
later let's exa grill subtle although I
got then you find out like a month later
you're like look there's a bump like
right here I got the Korean coupon I
dude I see everything you do you examine
it even when I picked up the Honda this
dude was like yo man everything's like
perfect as I actually know there's a
scratch here the front button the front
of plates are gone so the stickers are
still stuck on there I'm gonna get that
fixed and if you looking over here
there's a leak on that think you're
treating my [ __ ] sometimes well I think
I got [ __ ] over so many times every
time I got [ __ ] over I learned a new
lesson yeah yeah and now it's like so
when I picked the car I saw what was
wrong with it I was like it looks pretty
clean but I probably have to put like
another grand into it so he loaded down
like 600 bucks and then I see you know
what I do I know that I'm a [ __ ] a
hundred percent so I always bring
somebody with me
because if it's I use all my energy and
negotiation that after that
I'm so happy about the car I don't even
check it I'm all I think about is how
cheap and what of a discount I get and
that's it so this story here
so this couple who dropped off their
limited limited-edition Indy 500 Chevy
Camaro oh [ __ ] or a routine service hate
those new Camaros and the Chargers yeah
so this all happened in Montebello oh
that's nice yeah and so they only make
like a couple hundred of those really
there's only 200 oh wow 200 made a year
a year the this couple when they were
driving in the street they noticed that
their car their Chevy because you know
it's so it stands out the fact that it's
bright red and it has white stripe and
he they saw that their car just raced
down the street and they're like what
the [ __ ] so then they they went after it
and then this fool ends up pulling up to
a Tommy's which is a fast-food
restaurant
hamburger joint yeah and and that's when
the wife confronts the mechanic and so
we're gonna watch a video what are you
doing why are you test driving my car
you're getting food I Tommy I took my
car to the dealership where you could
change the oil and change the air does
he have a in the driveway the driver
seems to know he's in a jam well why are
you nervous you're getting me nervous
when you're supposed to be my car
dealership why are you doing it and no
words to say except you getting me
nervous I thought when you met joy I
like it's just like driving it around or
something I didn't know the person was
like drag race like just zooming off in
the streets and he was also getting fast
food you know there
learning to music it is you know the
Tommy burger - if he like not just like
in a now it's like Tommy my bad I take
back what I said I'd be thoroughly upset
yeah so and the woman said that this
isn't the first time that's happened in
the Montebello location because she said
she got her car serviced before and they
found a Taco Bell wrapper in the back
seat go to Pasadena and then and then
they're like oh no but it blew in
through the open window
wow the guys and the guys even was the
owner was just like well it happens all
the time it wasn't until like public
backlash that he apologized
you should what I do know is that when
mechanics fix your car they have to test
drive it they have to I mean I don't
know about this oil change but then
doing past when yeah I mean driving
irresponsibly none of that stuff is
supposed to happen but you know let's
say you get some work done on the tires
all this stuff they they they still do
have to drive it around the block or
something to make sure that everything
is cool but sometimes they go let me be
efficient and then they go I'm gonna go
to Taco Bell do this do that
pick up some hookers maybe you know
whatever and then go home you know
imagine the cars I get left overnight we
just keep going take them for dates and
stuff without you're scared it's like if
I someone's car was in my responsibility
I would Trevor doesn't put a hidden
camera in that mall [ __ ] yeah you know
I mean put like a GoPro on that
[ __ ] like hidden ooh catch
evidence that's pretty smart I like that
idea
with the GoPro well I don't have a car
so I can't get off the grip tape
[ __ ] give me my board I want you
to read
this you recording somebody else right
here skate what are you doing that's my
board get off my board [ __ ] so
you you go in you're gonna get some new
bearings something [ __ ] bushings I
need this overnight you're like cool I
trust you 100% you're at Venice and
there's [ __ ] out there [ __ ]
Jews in the [ __ ] grinding down everybody
you like give me my [ __ ] dude yeah give
me that [ __ ] bet you ain't but it's not
the same a skateboard is like so I can
always just go just get another one Oh
like cuz the one I am now has a Stevie
Wiebe show griptape that a fan-made so I
would know off top I'll be like that's
custom that's my skateboard [ __ ]
cuz I know there's only one of those
grip tapes out it's yours yeah how about
you Joe if you saw someone driving your
jag after it's supposed to be like being
serviced I don't care cuz it's a lease
unlike most people I don't hold
emotional value to physical items you
know as long as it's replaced I don't
care take a [ __ ] in my car make it smell
like it never existed
I don't care and so I'm saying what the
test I wouldn't care because it's a
lease but the elevator so yeah since you
bought it if it's yours then you'd be
pissed if I bought it I still don't
think so really you know why because I
feel like if I was a mechanic I'd be
that same [ __ ] you would do that and
I don't know we realtalk I'm so glad you
do this and not customer service [ __ ]
now I just can't see myself getting
angry over things like that something
about it I don't know it's just it's not
that big of a deal is it yeah it's just
things whatever whatever weight you far
[Laughter]
yeah
dude I would never [ __ ] with your
element I would just be like dude that's
my man never I've never been attached to
a vehicle before besides this car did
you get rid of the Accord the the Camry
I sold to my parents friends okay it's
only car I know you in yeah no I like
see I don't know what it is about I'm so
attached to me it took so long to find a
decent one you don't want to pick it up
pretty tight huh I think I think I put
some thought into it and I don't want to
miss inform the public and I think the
reality is I'm quite bipolar so if I'm
having a happy day my feelings are like
it's okay easy come easy go if I'm
having a bad day then I think that this
person is the enemy who [ __ ] murder
my grandma and if you drive my car then
you deserve your balls to be chopped off
while somebody inserts a spike with a
bat you know what the with the spike
spike on that in your buckle Oh
different salt do ya cuz their [ __ ]
skin is like a snail hey guys would you
think of that video I know you loved it
so make sure to hit that like button to
watch more videos and check it out up
here
[Music]